how can we and how can you support those
who served in uniform on Veterans Day
and frankly on every day that's a
subject of our closing angle remember
when General Kelly said this a few weeks
back most of you as Americans don't know
them many of you don't know anyone who
knows any of one of them but they are
the very best of this country produces
he's right of course yeah I know
veterans and most are too proud to ask
for help or they're too independent and
successful to need it on Veterans Day I
think of my father who died on his 88th
birthday back in 2013 there is he served
in the Navy in World War two at age 17 I
think we serve veterans by supporting
groups that actually get help to the
vets who need it there are a lot of
great groups out there the Wounded
Warrior Project homes for our troops and
Liberty USO just to name a few there are
a lot of them I think we serve veterans
by remembering their stories and telling
their stories to our children we serve
them by teaching our kids real history
the true history of our battles fought
and lost not a sanitized version that
gels with the politically correct mores
of the day our heroes aren't found at
the Oscars or the Grammy Awards they're
found in ceremonies from Medal of Honor
recipients like the one last month for
Vietnam vet Captain Gary Michael rose
after four days of constant engagement
with the enemy and after successfully
destroying an enemy base camp
Mike's unit prepared to evacuate when
the helicopters arrived Mike fought back
the enemy as his fellow soldiers boarded
the aircraft he boarded the last chopper
limping up to the craft while still
warding off the enemy forces that were
fast approaching back in January in 1989
Ronald Reagan reminded us of the
importance of teaching history in his
farewell address an informant patriotism
is what we want
and are we doing a good enough job
teaching our children what America is
and what she represents in the long
history of the world those of us who are
over 35 or so years of age grew up in a
different America we were taught very
directly what it means to be an American
and we absorbed almost in the air a love
of country
and an appreciation of its institutions
if you didn't get these things from your
family you got them from the
neighborhood from the father down the
street who fought in Korea the family
who lost someone at Anzio or you could
get a sense of patriotism from school
and if all else failed you could get a
sense of patriotism from the popular
culture the movies celebrated democratic
values and implicitly reinforced the
idea that America was special TV was
like that too through the mid 60s we've
got to teach history based not on what's
in fashion but what's important why the
pilgrims came here who Jimmy Doolittle
was and what those thirty seconds over
Tokyo meant if we forget what we did we
won't know who we are
I'm warning of an eradication of that of
the American memory that could result
ultimately in an erosion of the American
spirit let's start with some basics more
attention to American history and a
greater emphasis on civic ritual I could
watch that every day it's just amazing
those words are even more important
today than they were almost three
decades ago let's honor our veterans
with respect and gratitude for what they
sacrifice and support them for what they
deserve and what they need happy
Veterans Day to everyone out there who
served